hi [ __ ] what do you what do we call
the guy [ __ ] yes but I want to I want
there's there's new faces now there's
new faces on this episode so they might
have some better input both those
appendages hi dude you're good
hi ladies and gentlemen um I'm just
gonna do a quick roll call of who you
guys are listening to in your ear holes
right now hi me llamo es Gina know me
I'm Regina mm-hmm soy bingo how about
you so good
okay I'm gonna speak your language now
that's Gia oh yeah oh I'm TIFF and this
is Nikki I don't have headphones on oh
right yeah yeah a soft voice on and
today is gonna be a very special episode
because we got a really good friend and
fellow sister Christina up in the house
yeah you know I know we got to make her
feel real good she's a little bit
nervous right is it because crotch
goblin is about to burst out of you
lately so like every time the baby kicks
like I just have to pee yeah there's all
we feel like I'm like is he gonna come
out now well if you haven't already put
two and two together today we're gonna
be talking about pregnancies and what
they mean to all of us so right now we
have Christina who is how many months
pregnant I am I'm 28 weeks I don't even
know how to go by months anymore okay
baby will be here in two months oh so
fast so she's very good math good weeks
and then I had a baby two years ago TIFF
had a baby 11 years ago
nikki is trying to have a baby oh yeah
okay my bad I'm on prenatal sinking oh
she's getting her but wait like don't
gain more and don't lose more but if you
want if you're planning on having a baby
start taking prenatal vitamins two
months before you start trying nice and
she's like I love when people come in
here and they're like planning it
because you can do so much more not that
unplanned czar I was no we're not bad
people and it's always good I didn't
hurry up I didn't know yeah I mean I
wouldn't have known to prep if I didn't
just have my annual yeah yeah that's why
you should go to an annual yeah and then
we have Gina here who walls babies
[ __ ] crotch so we know her stance yeah
you love everyone else's baby yeah I
love no she does it I mean yeah she
calls she says she wants to slam tiger's
head those arms of endearment sweet
little butterfly okay she's you have to
protect her I have to protect her okay
Tiger can get a beggin for a bruisin
don't get heist like a football dude I
never hear you say anything about Isaac
I well I mean no I hugged the [ __ ] I
sweet him and then he got too big and
now he can fight me so I can't say
anything Isaac's no longer a crotch cop
yeah the full grown he is no longer with
hyolyn see so I love everyone's babies
but I am actively avoiding having a baby
because it scares the hell out of me
however I actually have been feeling
like you're gonna start buying a lot of
plants to like fill that void that like
needs a baby
no she got a guy yeah yeah that's the
person them yeah and then I'm actually
looking at getting plans yeah cats are a
gateway to plan because I'm feeling I'm
like okay
like at first it was like [ __ ] kids no
no no no thank you but now I'm like I
don't have kids before 35 like that
nurturing vibe is like yeah coming all
up yeah inside of you
yeah what is it that scares you um the
whole process of birthing and the whole
process of being pregnant like I've
heard some terrible for those you don't
know please look up on Google
third-degree vaginal tears so don't ya
do that don't do that this is a great
conversation because maybe maybe after
this Cristina myself and TIFF will suede
you the another way and I'm so glad that
Cristina's here because sometimes moms
that gave birth a while ago make me
forget all the pain they get like all
the struggle and some people live in you
and they lie and they why great humans
to continue to procreate because if
everybody warned each other like in
every remembered it forever yeah yeah
see see so let me hear what you're
afraid of and then we're gonna we're
gonna pull Christina in okay so she's
like an advocate for now so pregnancy
itself seems miserable because my
friends can't eat things what you're
like pregnant friends can't eat certain
things like sushi yeah or wine thank you
yes a couple years ahead got the plants
and cats correct me if I'm wrong but you
can have a glass of wine you can red
wine yeah that's true it's new news that
has been coming it doesn't have a glass
yeah like Gina will hear this and abuse
this rule get a big a glass of water
have a glass of wine also like just a
painting of it all everyone's like I
can't move my feet are swollen just like
everyone's like they're miserable and
like it just hurts my feet didn't get
swollen no and they're still not swollen
yeah every pregnant lady goes through
different they uh they're all different
and then morning sickness is I know my
girlfriend was puking all the time never
once puked but I did have nausea the
entire time see here's the thing like so
sad knowing me though and my should ask
look I may have all the above and I'm
gonna be like the worst person in the
world but on the flip side like I'm glad
you're prepping your body right now cuz
prenatals are the [ __ ]
yeah that and then your hair gets really
thick and it gets very luscious and
shiny okay great you can yeah I don't
want to have a baby
never hurts you oh yeah I know some men
that take it your nails get stronger
your complexion gets really nice why are
we not taking this all the time well I
guess like if your body can't absorb all
those vitamins like it just you just pee
em out and being over vitamins is the
thing so you careful that oh it just
like your body doesn't process the
vitamins as its supposed to because you
have it's too many see here's the thing
I don't drink water so I won't peed out
so my body oh yeah you know what drink
yeah you also force my body to absorb it
[Laughter]
is your P brown it's maple syrup Brown P
actually surprisingly never get you guys
wow that is very surprising right it is
strong down here I'm picturing your
vagina right now and I don't want you
it's great Nina
so you're on baby number two right now
yeah how has the pregnant she's been
different like have you noticed the
difference or is it exactly the same
honestly I would say it was it's
probably the same to me except it's kind
of like you're used to it so you kind of
know what to expect already so you're
probably I'm definitely more tired
because I'm dealing with the - you're
almost two year old and then you're
trying to like deal with the nausea
carrying the extra weight like sore
boobs and everything else - so it's like
I think I think you have a pro at it
though cuz like I honestly feel like
with the first one I didn't know how to
respond to it and like I was like
wearing all these like maternity clothes
I was wearing baggy stuff like I wasn't
cute you know but for like this one I'm
like you know what I don't care how I
feel about my body anymore like I'm
owning it yeah okay yeah just look
glowing like I get the whole pregnancy
glow thing from looking at you yeah yeah
I think like once you experience it the
first time you're just like you know
what like why why hide it you just
should embrace it and I'm like oh like I
have like bigger boobs they might be
sore and they might
be heavier they look great yeah thank
you look amazing thank you I have a
question yes okay after going through
the first pregnancy in your leg oh this
sucks like I feel all sore and like the
labor process and all of that stuff what
makes you like not even two years later
be like I'm ready to do it all over
again I want to know the thing I
honestly like I don't think you're ever
gonna be ready like no matter what even
if you've had like five kids or ten kids
like it's just something that you're you
have to tell yourself like does just lay
I need a sibling already like do you see
her by herself and she needs a friend
you feel like a [ __ ] it is a
straight up single like child density of
a dying son you know I mean like just a
raccoon holding a bowling ball that's
what Tech is I love him yeah like that's
a great question so I was thinking the
same thing because for me like I've been
like I'm 30 I'm 36 now so for me it's
like come on lady like is that you
talking to your vagina but I just and I
think about that right so that's this
that's the reason why I want to do it
again but for me I didn't have a fun
time being pregnant like the labor part
was really cool like I was good with
that because I expected it to be painful
it wasn't painful mom way better labor
experience than I did though to be your
[ __ ] boss but then for Tiff's like
you loved being pregnant uh yeah I
really liked it I loved feeling him
inside I like feeling him move and I
just felt like such a crazy bond in
connection with this person I've never
even met that I was creating like I
loved that even though I was nauseous
the whole time I was not in a very good
relationship where I was really sad
because of that but like just my
experience with my son was beautiful
like I would love to experience you're
the type of person that makes me want to
get pregnant like because that's how I
picture it being but then like you hear
me know it's like I hated it eat it
sucks and I'm like oh man I picture
myself glowing and get to touch child
forming it's yeah
yeah yeah but the but the actual labor
part freaks me the [ __ ] out
yeah absolutely I was good too but then
that's why I for the like for a long
time I kind of felt like I cheated and I
felt like I got Isaac too easily since I
had a c-section oh yeah so then for a
while like I didn't feel like I earned
him so yeah they'll feel that um weirdly
enough a little bit yes I still feel it
there are some people who are like oh
you're not a real mother unless you gave
birth exactly they're like oh you just
got a surgery you didn't give birth most
c-sections are because they have to do
it yeah just to judge someone like that
really that's really that's really fun a
c-section is actually way more intense
and way Hoyer surgery I was banking on
that just cut this [ __ ] outta me
no girl it's your ass yeah you have to
cut through the muscle it takes like
about a year no five years five years
Wow
completely healed yeah whereas when when
you give birth vaginally um I think I
was walking around the next day yeah
shame here you know yeah I don't feel
pain knowing for me I was a RM I guess
sexually she didn't feel pain cuz she's
like an epidural and all that even
absent when it wore off like I didn't
need like painkillers and like I mean it
hurt cuz I mean you just [ __ ] just
exploded you know but you recover so
much faster like for my recover way
faster yeah they actually let you stay
longer in the hospital if you have a
c-section then if you give natural birth
because for me the cutoff was five days
and I'm like I'm staying here until five
days like for for my labor experience so
I got that bad girl I think Joe was
telling me about her experience that
she's like oh my gosh it was so amazing
I didn't feel a thing so I think I'm the
anesthesiologist like he put the needle
I don't even know if I want to tell you
guys this no you put the needle like in
the wrong spot oh my gosh so my right
side of my body was completely numb but
my left side I fell
everything and they kept like putting
more and more and more I kept pushing
the button but like I still felt it so
when it came to like pushing and like
the labor and the baby coming out like I
felt it but like but on a good note what
but what is there possibly but what but
after like going through that it's been
less than two years and I'm already
gonna have another baby you know like
you kind of forget about tnut stuff
you're [ __ ] gangster okay
you played at pool halls in high oh
that's true you're part of the star
cruiser hey you have street cred Oh
girls true I learned a lot about
Christina on our girls trip when we
played never have I ever would never
have guessed that in my blood so it's
such a nurturing like good mom like such
a like you know like happy I never would
have guessed you were like where we were
in the car together driving home welcome
tea and then like Christina said
something I made I almost made Gio slam
on the brakes so I can turn around like
[ __ ] you say are you serious
that's something we can talk about
online okay we don't want to do in a
memory that you weren't actually thank
you though we want you there or it's
because she can't stop texting us inside
got you shut the [ __ ] up so my my
brother's wife just gave birth and she
was gonna do it naturally because know
she works at a hospital and she was
talking about how she's seen people get
paralyzed from the needle dog oh yeah
please and then I'm like I've never used
the needle now but then I'm like oh then
she when she went through labor she what
it had yeah she called me and she's like
she was all drugged up I think you just
do the drug
it's not worth the just changed her mind
real quick yeah dude that's not so when
I gave Britt Isaac that day that I was
supposed to so we had this appointment
so they could flip him over cuz his head
when his head supposed be down reach
straight yeah he was breached use words
like that like they broke into your body
you know what people breach and do like
wouldn't there Hank when SWAT teams
breach your house oh I think of a whale
breaching or that I don't want a whale
or SWAT team coming out you know no I
think the one that looks really painful
is a traverse where the baby's sideways
like oh yeah anyway so the day that I
was they were supposed to flip him over
I went in and I was already in labor
which means I couldn't go through with
the procedure which would mean that they
have to inject a certain medication to
loosen up the uterus muscle to like
manually move him from outside I wanted
to go through that because I really
wanted to experience having him natural
but it didn't work out because super
dangerous right yeah it's so like the
court could get wrapped her on his neck
which he actually did when he was born
but which is very common but yeah when I
went in they said nope you're already in
labor what's your pain level from zero
to ten I'm like oh no like a 0.5 like it
was really low and they were like really
you're having really strong contractions
right now so I was like oh my god nice
proud I could do that I could really do
this so for the next kid if it happens
hopefully I want to try to have him
natural so without drugs cuz I was like
dude my body could probably handle it
yeah I think you can knowing all of the
things that you like thrive for and
stuff like I'm better I think you're
just gonna be like you're gonna hype
yourself up during your labor okay give
birth while skydiving if she could comes
out faster I'm behind I've had friends
who actually went natural like to within
the last year and they said they pushed
for like five to ten minutes and the
baby was it the first baby
the first baby yeah that natural yeah
because you're not numb so you feel
every little thing through and like it's
just so much easier to like push them
out and then how long did you have to
push for I pushed for an hour
cuz you were half now is half
yeah I have a question about way unless
did you want to say something no okay
think oh I have a question about being
pregnant because I have a theory of how
I'll be while I'm pregnant
but I don't know if that theory is true
and so how are you during PMS week
um I'm usually pretty good so I feel
like okay so when you're pregnant um
it's kind of like a more intense like
that's my theory in intense PMS week
yeah so I think I would be a psychopath
oven mitts around your hand well you
know what we're not gonna hide from you
guys right now it's gonna be our first
sponsor no that's why I was like oh did
you need to say your internal clock is
tickin more that way late cravings late
night Oh TIFF coming in hot door - yes
so um I personally love love love door -
and guys if you just gave birth or gonna
give birth or whatever at door - is your
[ __ ] best friend I know when I had
just given birth the last thing you want
to do is go in the kitchen and try to
find what you're gonna eat
so door - has thousands of different
restaurants that you can pick from and
they deliver it straight to your door
like what a time to be alive you know
saying uh do they - to your door they do
they - from their door make sure it says
if I don't see that [ __ ] running from
down the street I want so it connects
you to your favorite restaurants in your
city ordering is easy you just download
their app you enter your zip code and it
shows you like a smorgasbord of
different places where you can eat
there's over three hundred and ten
thousand amazing restaurants there's
local goat cheese or cheese from your
favorite chains like Chipotle or
cheesecake that was a hard pee so yeah
you don't have to worry about dinner or
you don't have to like stress it if
there's like a party that you're putting
together you can order from there and
you can guarantee that it's going to be
at your place um so for everyone
listening right now you're gonna get
five dollars off your first order of
fifteen dollars or more when you
download the door - app and enter promo
code hey girl hey girl that's H ey GI RL
so that's five dollars off your first
order when you download the door - app
from the App Store and enter promo code
hey girl
and again it's hey girl
for five dollars off your first order if
I head door - ball pregnant I would get
so fat it's ok you don't have to worry
about getting fast ygo cuz our next
sponsor is here to help you and then
we're introducing new has anyone tried
new yes yes I love it cuz new him does
this new approach where they're they're
treating a diet not about the food but
more so about the habits that you are
the habits and the choices that you make
that lead you into the right or the yeah
they did you all like the psychological
asks a Qui you form that habit and how
to break those habits what I think is
really cool I've never seen a diet and
exercise program do that before yeah and
I think that's why they're successful
rate is so high because they're not
about like count this and do this
they're more like okay what's going on
in that headspace of yours and we can go
from there and now we can build it out
to help you be successful
I put the fork down they will tell you
why you can't put the fork down and what
you can do to break that habit yeah so
you learn to resist temptations when you
go out and be comfortable in social
environments cuz a lot of people I hear
that all the time like oh my job is this
or I'm stressed out because of this or
you know you know there's so many
parties or it's holiday season is
approaching so this is perfect for
anyone that wants to lose some weight in
a very healthy way so sign up for your
trial today at noon that's N oom calm
slash b tch visit Noom comm slash b tch
to start your trial today that's new
calm sea hey Shh alright so let's talk
about stitches did you get stitches I
didn't have to get stitches yeah my
little nail is my knees your per diem I
hear about that did you prep it how do
you like what you like
take your fingers in there that's what a
turn I didn't do it how do you do I
almost I actually stuck a tampon in the
wrong way once and I wanted to die you
do I don't know man it's wrong the wrong
maybe all right like maybe if you guys
are just straight up just squeezing
babies out I'm just like how do you do
it with nails though oh hey girls and
fingers take them off yeah take your
nails off I didn't do any of that and I
did tear like yeah yeah they go dome
look at his daddy birth to like a
Volkswagen Beetle is that a good thing I
don't know more no because I did tear
but I didn't feel it I didn't feel any
of that like I'm telling you I had the
best labor experience that you can like
they were like you're you have
contractions now so push and I was like
oh really okay cool and it was just like
I felt like I was in the weight room
like just squatting some heavy weight
because wait see that that actually does
help I heard like if you're physically
active before he won't [ __ ] work oh
[ __ ] you need to hydrate to come out
Krusty's [ __ ] years the like really
build yourself up in this direction
walking every day so in the movies when
people are like screaming in the
delivery room movies it's it's not like
that oh no wait wait unless you do
natural you know well I mean yes because
my aunt it was the only birth I got to
watch and she was exactly like the movie
she was like red head ginger dry they
hear that it's more painful for them why
I don't know yeah yeah google it yeah
yeah redheads are stereotypically freaky
in bed and then they have like really
crazy Labor's no I heard that never
heard that part go back to your question
that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah so I didn't feel anything so once I
gave birth to tyka my doctor was like
okay so I'm just gonna sit you up real
quick because you did to her a little
bit and I was like okay where did you
tell her where yeah where exactly I
didn't look under her vagina or like no
cuz there's like different ways like
like if I had to
wait so if this is this is my hole right
well this is my hole yeah you guys see
cuz it's so little this is my hole
Michael it's here right my butt holes
here then I guess this part yeah but you
know I had a girlfriend who tore all the
way yeah that's a degree yeah so one big
hole you had anal fissures
she could have boobs straight like for
the longest time I see a turd don't they
um offer to cut it yeah you don't have
to tear it so you have like a clean it
yes yeah yeah yeah this is real do you
know like the cut it with scissors oh
you don't feel like Gina when I was
doing research and I was pregnant
looking into all that stuff back then
they recommended that you just that the
doctor just cut you because it's a nice
clean cut instead of a tear that's all
jagged and it's like it's harder to heal
that way but then what if you're not
you're not prone to ripping then you
just have a cut for no reason like for
me I know I guess the doctor would see
like a professional Georgia natural I
think it's the same response at
different reactors like yeah they tear a
hole from your vagina to your about all
what you don't feel it dude I had a huge
hole because of because you know
c-section but honestly it was not that
bad it was not you lying [ __ ]
everybody are like oh yeah so terrible
survival instincts by the way so I think
like uh like having to do this topic cuz
a lot of like viewers and stuff like
they're always asking about like you
know my labor and all that stuff and I'm
like yo I can't remember a lot of it I
know I felt like I remember all of it
but then like honestly though like and
you're like let's do it again yeah
psycho I felt like a psycho for that
because I didn't know I was gonna be
ready to have a kid that quickly like
after experiencing that too and I'm just
like oh gosh I'm gonna do it again I'm
ready like I'm pumped this time I'm I'm
not like scared or anything like you
know when I went into labor I started
having contractions at home and I was
just like okay um oh you know if I was
like yeah and then I was like okay well
I guess I have time cuz they tell you to
before you go in there or you're just
gonna be in the emergency room for a
long time so I was like okay I'm gonna
like shower I'm gonna get ready I'm
gonna put some makeup on you know I want
to look decent when I'm in labor it was
just like saying online a lot of
pictures we're not just that but like it
helps them get through yeah yeah
distracts them cuz you're just like
you're so calm and you're just doing
whatever like just to soothe yourself
and you're like you are distracted
because if you're rushing to the
emergency room you're literally gonna be
laying there with like all these wires
and like things like plugged into you
and you're just gonna be waiting for
them to be like okay well you're this
many and you're gonna be here for like
another I don't know like 10 15 hours or
something so you do make up while you're
like waiting for it just to last it yeah
shower yeah some people laundry sounds
[ __ ] psychotic don't like your vagina
open you have so much like dopamine or
what's that one drug we have serotonin
yeah there's just so you're so on high
after you give birth and I think it's
just nature and you you just love
everything and you're just you're just
that's so true yeah so like if you're in
this like you 4x state where you're just
like you would like appreciate women
more it's like the weirdest [ __ ] ever
you're just like so in love with
everything and you cry easily because
you're just so happy more and more like
a cult as you speak you feel like you
have superpowers who could you like wow
I just went through all of your mind
blocks out memories when it's terrible
so the fact that I've blocked out the
fact that labor is [ __ ] terrifying
this is a good time during labor you see
there's just it's just a memory favorite
that I hate it amber having a bad time
but you don't like you can't physically
recall it enough to like not one I
remember after giving birth or not being
able to walk or like I remember being
like a hunchback because I couldn't
extend my torso yeah which I wanted to
ask you guys like is that the same thing
for you guys don't know you're back to
normal yeah other than just being sore
in the crotch area and like bleeding
straight for riding
you're bleeding straight for a month you
are nowheres to wear like that they also
give you a bottle like a squeeze bottles
oh you're like big day yourself down
there it's gnarly are you ready yeah it
does well yeah but I continually being
on the fence I feel like you guys are a
cult and I like I'm starting to enjoy
and like they're making someone told me
to bring a friend yeah you guys but
really just imagine this okay so let's
get all the yucky [ __ ] out of the way
okay okay so now you found the partner
that like you want to create life with
right and there's so many things that
you love about this partner so imagine
Steve I already got that part what why
you ruined that part so this is dope but
then Steve has bad parts to him right
where you're like goddamn it right he's
a human oh [ __ ] you you know really like
I really love every single thing about
it okay who's gonna do the laundry he
doesn't so now imagine oh right diaper
but he doesn't so now so now picture
this relationship that you have with him
and it's so [ __ ] beautiful right and
now you guys bring like the best parts
of each other out and now you get to see
it and it loves you and it hugs you and
it calls you mom and I mean you can't go
to a restaurant because it screams or a
movie I go to a restaurant I've traveled
the world great but you said it was hard
yeah worth it is hard but like right now
we travel it's really great it's really
fun it's not hard at all it's a vacation
Jim and true it is a vacation and it's
definitely not a vacation anymore but
it's a different experience and it's
type of vacation rethink your idea of
vacation and then you'll be fine
vacation but not just you know you learn
to love pain and I think you'll really
like this see that's the thing one your
child is my nightmare because that
[ __ ] came out ten pounds that's insane
to me
I'm not 411 it's shy I'm very capable to
carry a [ __ ] monster
is that was casitas kid she would be
split in half currently yeah I would
have had that anal fissure yeah like I'm
still so well I mean part of the reason
why I don't have kids now is because I'm
still so selfish
like I want my life I love sleeping in I
still want to travel I like having money
but having a kids is selfish - you don't
need a kid that's true that's true but
also i partly want kids for selfish
reasons because when I'm old as [ __ ]
that's exactly what I'm saying yeah on
the same level right so great the damn
clanking about Christmases being lonely
right later exactly like so we need a
family I'm picturing it with kids do we
have to have a family for Christmases
and stuff but then like the other part
of me is like oh I really like our life
right now right like I really know what
you guys haven't even touched on and
this is the part that George gets your
[ __ ] camera ready the [ __ ]
breastfeeding party meta-genome we have
lonely Christmases be okay with each
other it's fine yeah but no kids back
yeah yeah wet if you're ready to see her
at like 5:00 p.m.
yeah and you're not gonna see her until
like late I mean you know she'll she
wakes up when I go to bed so she tucks
me in I'll wake up when she's going to
bed we'll share cats and plants even
this equation you'll be their dad
somewhere so I guys want to know about
breastfeeding I heard that I heard it
hurts like hell all on your nipples man
like it's painful so scared of chafing
or like cracking cracked nipples and
Dryden I was so terrified at that that
after feeding him every time I would
always put that lanolin yeah this is
great guys I really hope that this is
really I remember
I don't even know what other stuff
uh-huh I just know I've seen the word
before but I just want you guys though
right now this is not helping at all
I mean none of this is helping section
good luck trying to sleep why why I
could not sleep for [ __ ] because my tits
were rock-hard and sores why I couldn't
sleep because there's milk and it's
Chauncey was like your tits get really
big Don like you can't touch them no cuz
they're really sore and hurt a lot and
then because of the fact that I had a
c-section like I couldn't I had to be
sleeping with so many pillows behind me
that I was like sleeping up like
straight don't get a c-section there
don't get us these x-rays there's a
solution ever you can't deny found a
solution you until these people came out
and ruined it for me
right exactly here's a solution I'm
gonna make enough money to have a
surrogate yeah but you're not gonna love
your baby as much it's gonna be dad I
will love him for not [ __ ] my life up
the reason why the reason why I said
that is because I want you [ __ ] to go
through the same [ __ ] and then
here's another subject I want to touch
on I am terrified of having children
because I like I already knows about me
especially now I cannot have like a
heavily disabled child I can't no I
can't I can't do that I can't take care
of that I don't have a lead disable chat
what does that mean poorly or physically
disabled child oh I wouldn't be oh yeah
you'd be able to nurse no I don't think
your mothering instincts would kick in I
don't know that's a thing
well me now I see that now and I don't
know yeah but if it's like very like
life well this is help that there's
tests for that in the first trimester
well but there's also chance but there's
also things that don't develop till
later on which scares the [ __ ] out of me
too like that that's why I'm afraid of
giving birth because if I had a child
that was very much disabled and can't
live on his own I'm afraid of what's
gonna happen to me like if I die who's
gonna take care of him and I like I I'm
like what if he wants like he'll never
be able to like get married because
whatever and stuff like that and that
breaks my heart
and that is the most terrifying there's
a lot of people who live normal lives
absolutely yeah you should watch vlogs
of it yeah I just started watching this
channel called special books by special
kids have you heard of that yeah well
yeah like it's really it's really
interesting because you actually to
learn how those families operate and
like every single one of them the family
is like we [ __ ] love this child and
but you're just happy do they say that
because they mean it or they say yeah
cameras on Oh tell you about my aunt so
my aunt she has a daughter and a older
son and then her last kid the third kid
he came out with Down syndrome mhm and
this lady she was like she's super super
selfish she's very funny Alyssa like
been of a super vein hmm but she's
really loving but she would be the last
person I ever imagined would have a
disabled child but she ended up having
my cousin has Down syndrome and she like
poured herself into him and right now my
cousin's about 19 and so he's still
heavily dependent on her but she she's
still there like this is her kid you
know like there's no way that anything
that he puts her through or like that
should they have to go through together
cuz he has heart problems too so he has
to have surgery sometimes like he gives
her so much life and so much joy yeah
like she's constantly saying like she
cannot imagine her life without him and
crazy and I don't mean to make you feel
bad but literally everyone thinks that
yeah I know like I don't know everyone
thinks that it's very normal
yeah I know that everyone thinks i but
it's just I feel like other people are
just like oh yeah I'm so ready to be a
mother and I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna do that and I'm just like if I had
like if I'm talking like cannot even
breathe on it on its own baby kind of
thing like if I had that I don't know if
I can handle that and also I think it
was like some sort of statistic that
says that that like when you have a
disabled child like that it breaks apart
marriage is like quickly like you know
like a lot of people I mean that's just
kids too though yeah and that's it's
anything yeah this statistics and that's
anecdotal like you know statistically
50% of marriages end in divorce but like
if you find the person for you it's not
like you know like there's I think that
if you have a strong bond before you
have a child like I don't know if you're
that in danger of divorce if you guys
have the same values and stuff yeah but
oh yeah they give you tests where you
can find out if you have that percentage
and then also like I don't know this is
kind of spiritual but I kind of believe
like you know you know you've the
universe like gives you what you need
yeah what you're supposed to have what
you can handle yeah absolutely think
that you can't take care of you know
yeah and it's crazy that we're talking
about this - cuz like this is something
that I'm actually going through right
now so usually like what the testings
that you're talking about they have it
like within certain time frames where
you can get it done so usually like if
you're talking about like a baby that
has a hard time breathing like that's
something they might they should be able
to detect in the beginning okay so for
us like we had to do the second
trimester testing and then something
happened like with the lab there's
something that you're supposed to get
like within 18 to 20 weeks because it's
so crucial like if they have problems
like you have a decision to make like
this test is to test for any extra
problems or if they have down syndrome
and then the lab or whoever the UPS they
messed up with my blood work and never
got tested so I I never got results for
it and now like I'm in a situation where
I got an inanimate Rahsaan where they do
like in the extensive ultrasound and
then they found like calcium in the
baby's heart so that's usually like an
indication yeah yeah yeah so right now
that's like what we're dealing with and
we're kind of waiting like we did the
blood work again and we're waiting just
to get test results so like all the
concerns that you're talking about
that's like something literally right
now yeah crazy and it's like I'm already
so far in like I just hit my third
trimester so I'm trying to mentally
prepare myself to be like okay am I
gonna be a good mom yes like everything
that you're seeing is like hitting close
to home cuz there's a chance he might
not have it but there is that chance
that he will so it's like what am I
gonna do am I gonna be a good mom you
know can I handle it so it is something
that happens but like I feel like no
matter what if he does have down
syndrome like I'm gonna take care of him
I'm still gonna love him just as much
you know so I really feel like the
universe will give you more than you can
handle so exactly absolutely
grandmother Jodie are you're so
inspiring from hoodrats a great mother
that's a [ __ ] wonderful that's a
wonderful book that's what made me
stronger
yeah the pool appearances prepare you
for everything that you're gonna take on
later in life yeah yeah whatever you
can't handle you can always turn to that
was really good tell me about stalks
days oh boy okay so I'm gonna go off
this a little bit away from this a
little bit stalks me said something that
I use personally it's um it's an online
therapy app that makes taking care of
your mental health more affordable and
convenient than ever before so I like it
because instead of waiting like once a
month once every two weeks or whatever
to talk to your therapist this is a
mobile app you can message them as much
as you want so when you're going through
it you can message them while you're
going through instead of just bottling
it all in and then sitting on the couch
and talking with them so how I use it is
whenever I'm having a bad day whenever
I'm going through something really bad
or like thoughts or whatever happening I
messaged her and or I can text I can
text message her I can voice message her
I can video message her and then a
therapist and licensed therapist will
check their phones twice a day five days
a week and they'll respond to you and
they'll talk to you and they'll give you
exercises to do so what happened what I
did or what happens is that you go on to
the app you kind of take a quiz about
like what you want to deal with what you
have and then they'll match you with a
bunch of therapists and you pick one and
you start talking to them so that way
like I never feel like I'm alone like I
just have someone on my phone at all
times so with talk space finding the
right therapist doesn't have to be
stressful the talk space matching
process takes your unique preferences
into account to find you someone whose
style and expertise matches your needs
and if you want to switch therapist you
can do that any time at no extra cost
it's also very affordable one month
therapy on the talk space platform cost
but the same amount as a single
face-to-face session so like for one
month of messaging whatever you want it
cost for it's the same classes all just
one single face-to-face session that's
way more affordable best of all you'll
never have to wait a week to share
what's on your mind
so talk space has more than 5,000
licensed therapists who are experienced
in addressing the challenges that we
face to match
perfect therapist for a fraction of the
price of traditional therapy go to talk
space calm and make sure you use the
code b-tch to get sixty five dollars off
your first month mm-hm and show your
support for the show that's b-tch at
talk space.com shout out to my therapist
maria i love her yeah she gonna put tune
on her friend she know what she is not a
mexican maria no she's just Maria Maria
Maria alright so I'm super excited
introduce our next monster this is for
all my single people out there you're
not a little what's so funny Oh some
super absolutely I get in it I jump in
it because I'm just excited about this
app yea what's exciting gee Lois first
of all I wish I was on this app what for
meeting my husband by the way this hinge
hinge yes thank you hinge sorry about
that yes thank you to our sponsor hinge
I'm super excited about this app because
it's a dating app and sorry not like a
hookup it's not yeah it's a dating app
where they want you to actually find
love connections relationships yes stuff
with their motto you already have right
geo absolutely but I'm jealous she's
excited for me yeah yeah but what's
their motto their motto is designed to
be deleted which i think is really cool
because most of the other dating apps
out there and the reason people get so
sick of dating apps is because it just
became a hook-up place like people just
like gimmicks and stuff but they're
making something yeah like cycling
through all the people in their city and
they're not ever settling down right
like it's just for guys cuz girls get
that just in a regular basis right I
don't think you know we don't need an
app for all that stimulus no but Jess
okay she's got a small she's got some
things to show how do you know Jessica's
here I'm pretty I'm pretty happy with
the quality of men that I've seen so far
on their the quality of their profiles
like they actually have to put several
pictures up so it's not just like one is
that him is that or that is that his
friends I can't tell who this guy is
people are actually uploading really
cool and artistic looking photos there's
this one guy that's like kind of sitting
naked and in a pool of water like in the
middle of a desert and I love that photo
there's also like
a lot of really cool questions getting
all Jessa's kinks I just it just feels
like kind of like a cool and you get a
broad range of who they are as a person
it's really fun the next pictures in
helping children stories for an actual
episode but hinge thank you for
sponsoring us because I wouldn't even
have thought to download this happened
then now that I have them like oh my
gosh way better than get like
rejuvenated your watch no you know where
is your mind it's on hinge girl because
I'm jealous like if my [ __ ] doesn't work
out with my man and our son into the box
but I'm definitely jealous that when I
was growing up I didn't have this
because it seems like you were saying
there's a lot of quality people you get
to see several windows and they didn't
even have phones we didn't have mobile I
know I know what is that do you even
know what it felt like the rotary bones
are anyway that's what we're here to
talk about okay we're gonna talk about
freaking hinge and how good it is I did
see on your profile that you were able
to put that you like to drink and then
that like religion yeah yeah and I put
maybe on kids too just so they know yeah
just so they know maybe I want kids
maybe I don't you do not eliminate that
whole and then oh and you showed me the
importance of that so you get to so now
like it gives you this really cool
algorithm that you can say that this is
X amount of important to me versus this
one that's not that important to me but
I'm still considering it and then it
starts filtering people that way too
which i think is really cool yeah damn
so for all of you people out there that
think you're loved
yeah you're just not gonna find the one
damn George over there I have to always
put him on blast every time he found the
one and he deleted the app after he
found the one it works it's work don't
sleep on it yeah dude thanks so much for
sharing that I think like that's very
powerful that like someone like you with
your fan base and stuff you get to be so
open about it because now people are
gonna feel less alone and like [ __ ] is
something you know wrong with me or like
am I gonna be able to get through with
this and you're just here so strong
being like go unfortunately this is the
setbacks that we had but I'm gonna be
very positive about it and
like I have you know my supporting
husband and I have my daughter we're
gonna nothing's gonna change I'm gonna
love him as much as you know like
anything else you know so I think that's
[ __ ] speaking of that I think that
you started your channel awesome like
helping other women with pregnancy
concerns with the you had a miscarriage
and you were very open about that and
I've found like through talking other
women that it is so common and but when
you're going through it you feel like
you're the only one and not enough women
talk to each other about it and I really
didn't know how common it was until you
came on our podcast and was talking
about it there and and then that's when
other women were talking about it's me I
was like whoa this is very very common
because I think if I would have tried
and gotten pregnant and then had a
miscarriage I would I would feel like oh
no like I can't maybe I can't do it like
yeah right but knowing that that's
something that that can happen and it's
if you're trying right now and that's
happened to you like you are not broken
and I think that's so great that you use
your channel in that way and that you've
been able to share your experiences and
be so open because it is so private and
it's been built up to be so private and
unfortunately it leaves a lot of women
feeling alone yeah I mean like I feel
like there's this stigma where when you
go through like miscarriages or baby
loss or like infertility people are
always like oh don't talk about it like
there's something wrong with you and you
just don't want to get judged but it is
really calming like with miscarriages
one in three pregnancies always end up
like pregnancy a lot yeah it's not that
there's something wrong with your body
like if it's your first pregnancy that's
just like your body's natural way of
fighting it because it doesn't know what
it is it feels like something's
attacking it so I mean it there's
nothing wrong with you and I think that
was the message I wanted to give to
people because it took me a while to
decide that you know we're ready to try
again I think it took us like a year to
get over it yeah and you know just like
having people like reach out to us like
after we started posting all these
videos and like sharing the air
experiences I was just like oh wow like
this happens all the time and like when
you share that kind of bond like with
your audience like it just makes it feel
like it's okay yeah and you really don't
feel alone like I've had people who
they've messaged me and they're like you
know what I'm going through a
miscarriage right now like I'm waiting
for the for everything to just come
I'm like wow like for you to be able to
even come to me and like talk to me
about that stuff like I felt like I felt
good that's really really Ellie I turned
something negative into a positive and
like after that I feel like it just made
me stronger yeah cuz I would have
thought because you guys you got the the
pregnancy test and it was positive and
then you told like you told everyone
right away yeah
the channel started and then that's what
led I mean after that was the
miscarriage and I would have thought the
same thing like oh it says positive but
pregnant we're doing the baby exact and
yeah I didn't I didn't know all that how
common it was yeah wow what in three
that's what yeah yeah about it that's
such a traditional mindset to like Shh
yeah back in the day people thought that
like or at least men were like ah I want
a son and she keeps giving me a [ __ ]
girl yeah you know he can't give me a
child she's right it would always blame
the woman for this but now like that
we've we have a lot more scientific data
that that what it's like nah dude it's
like kids are [ __ ] miracle like yeah
the fact that like you go through nine
months and then you finally give birth
like that and the sex comes from the
sperm yeah it does it comes from the
book all you Kings that beheaded your
wives yeah it really is a miracle like
just how like the [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] millions of sperm like they have
to impregnate or they have to like
penetrate this one little egg like just
the beginning of it it's just it's
amazing we were old miracle yeah I'm the
dumbass sperm that one I've ever been in
my life so far yeah I made it I'm good
what other things are you guys
considering where you're just like damn
like option okay so I'm not really like
this is a more like spiritual thing but
I feel like I chose to have a human
experience and I want to do all parts of
that human experience so if I'm a woman
in this lifetime I want to experience
motherhood and on all and creating life
and all of that stuff if I can if it's
if I'm able to I'd like to have that
experience because the only
you get one life that you remember and
so you know even if you believe in
reincarnation like you only remember
this one time so like I want to play it
out the entire way like I want to so
you're gonna Yolo it and do a bunch of
[ __ ] drugs no well yeah but um
the only specific kinds that I
researched a lot like and then also I
was like a heroin but okay cool not
heroin but I am considering DMT have you
guys you just like I leave your body you
different conversation but I feel like a
while on drugs each one will do a
different drug and we'll see how I pop I
pick weed I want ecstasy rubbing them I
know I want at one point I wanted to try
every single drug and then I read all of
the bad things that could happen off
each one and I crossed the ball off
before doing them you're funny TIFF um
for you you haven't been I was Lucy a
mom that's a stupid be even pregnant it
was what I'm trying to get out yeah for
11 years do you have like any
reservations or you're just like done it
wants cake no yeah so actually going
back to the whole miscarriage talk like
by you being so vocal about your
experience Christina it really made me
think about because you know Casey and I
are trying and we really would like to
have a kid and I've been talking to
Christina a lot about this too and and
so like the fact that you've been too
open about that it makes me think like
well if it does happen I would like to
share it with everyone and cuz you know
how they like old-school thinking is
just very like you're not supposed to
say integrated like three months or
something like that like once you know
there's a safe period and for me
personally I found strengthen to in
being very open if anything would go
wrong because of your experience so like
I'm just hoping that I know
it's really good at making people cry
you notice you notice that it's always
you know said it was the only the
mothers that were crying
having a kid makes you a [ __ ] Nikki
head watery eyes I never cry no but yeah
I mean like I I I'm so excited and I
really really that's why I'm still very
like well I don't know we'll see you
because I don't want to deep down inside
I'm fighting it but I'm really like oh
my god I want to be bad right now are
you fighting it every time you put your
face close to Christina you're talking
to a baby are you really fighting you
know you're doing a good job fighting it
never imagined imagine if I wasn't and
the older you get I feel like the more
you want like I I do feel the baby like
my ovaries are taking over my logic side
of my brain I find that every time I
pass like a couple with a toddler or
child I get jealous like so jealous like
you can be a baby I need to get one
that's opposite for me cuz I'm like I'll
see you can't like oh my god you're so
damn cute and then I'll hear another one
screaming I'm like right never mind I'm
on the fence like that too but I think
the older I get like the more the
ovaries side takes over and drowns out
there you know think about your perfect
ideal mate perfect think about him right
what does he look like I will be Jordan
right okay so that's your ideal he's
everything you've ever wanted
hi okay okay I can now imagine you going
oh my god I want your [ __ ] baby you
know I mean - like trap is a sure cuz my
ideal man is good-looking he's hella
rich - so I'm a trap that ass real quick
so then now you're down okay yeah no I'm
done I guess oh this is a business
decision no yeah I said like I've I've
met someone that I thought was my soul
mate and you know I wanted a kid with
him so I understand have you gotten
pregnant you look at like
right now are you oh yeah it's been a
recent like being a couple months few
months ago be yeah but that was the
thing that scared me about getting
pregnant too because it's like I thought
this was my soulmate um you know and I
was fully ready like okay look we're
gonna get Mary we're gonna have kids
I've never seen myself having kids with
anyone else but unfortunately that
didn't work out because I had to think
logically and I was like okay so maybe
you and I are not meant to be but you
are my soul mate cuz I believe multiple
soul mates right but that was the first
time having that thought and when that
ended it really hurt Gina you have a
hard blow this out we're talking great
tales like a shower yeah we have some
tissue next to you Oh Gaby thank you but
that was the only time I'm like okay I
really want a kid and that's when I like
seriously thought about like okay I want
to have kids and I told him to I was
like you know tissues [ __ ] that was
the first time ever felt like I want to
have kids like look I wanna have kids
before 35 but unfortunately our lives
you think match up so that ended and you
know it's sad but you know it's the way
of life and I had to you know yeah oh oh
it was very much yeah you threw us off
cuz we were like wow we're never gonna
get both everyone a [ __ ] and we'd never
thought we were gonna crack her
okay [ __ ] you I'm in the cold I'm in the
cold any any other questions you guys
have because I'm not gonna remember a
lot of this stuff right right I mean
you're in it you brought up the pic in
the bet the breastfeeding and even if
you breast pump it still hurts right
yeah yeah and but okay so like compare
that you know how you're like all the
labor and stuff but it's worth it cuz
you're almost dopamine and all this
stuff everyone like everything feels
good after okay so when you're I always
pictured breastfeeding as like I'm
giving life to this child you feel that
yes okay so you balance its so if you'd
be like my nipples are falling off
there's an amazing bond with nursing
it's like I loved it oh I [ __ ] love
you I didn't think I could love you more
than I love you already
yeah yeah dude my nipples were bleeding
oh no they learn oh that's only the
beginning though because they're not
used to it amazing that your body
created life and then continues to
sustain life that's insane to me and
you're gonna feel that like when I have
that experience
you're gonna feel that I could you know
it could be surrogate as much what we're
feeling right now you feel that times
like a hundred and you start looking at
women and you're like holy [ __ ] your
[ __ ] goddess see that already has
happened to me like ever since wanting
to have a child whenever I see someone
have a baby like when you were pregnant
I was just I couldn't stop like every
time I saw you I was like hi baby
oh hi Gio Wonder I'm like I'm so like
happy to be a woman in that way where
I'm like I can't believe our bodies can
actually create human beings that's
insane to me and I still look at women
that way we're like especially Rick
right now looking at one that's creating
a life I'm like wow this is this you're
a magician people just make fun of right
now can you slicin see the thing is
would you it's a different reason why is
I damn [ __ ] dope not because she made
a thing
a bigger creature a creature inside
gonna get nice I think it's not because
she made this thing inside of her nine
months but because this [ __ ] got skinny
again in like a month
oh it was not a month really I cuz you
still was great thank you it was
definitely a year really yes you fat is
me like no I was really my best and then
even how I was before I got pregnant but
that's one thing to I want to stress and
I think you went through this too where
like you kind of just chill like like I
was at first when I was pregnant like oh
I can't get wait I can't wait to bounce
back I can't wait to start exercising
that count weight and then I was like
wait why why am i rushing it like I'm
like I should just be spending this time
with my child yeah just focusing on like
like maintaining my breasts I mean my
breasts my my milk production you know
and like like I was just stressing out
about that bounce back that I was just
not living in the moment and I'm like
why the [ __ ] do I care like let's just
chill it's cuz it was you're so public
like our lives are so public to and you
were like publicly also in the fitness
arena so I'm sure there was a lot of
pressure on you to like get back like AB
like more than normal yeah yeah some
fitness people who are were pregnant and
they still got out I'm like your baby's
head on the baby's head okay it seems
when she got pregnant it was like a
scooty like for her leanest that she's
ever been but then like a little labor
yes well I just tell myself that they
have to make a living so they have that
pressure and then I got so rou I go I
don't have to I don't have to make a
living on it so I'm gonna take myself
exactly and I did and I thought that was
the best decision I think so too
especially like when you start valuing
your mental health over this like
physical appearance and you're in sleep
deprived and you're constantly hungry if
you're breastfeeding and then you're
constantly thinking about producing more
milk and like yeah you're just [ __ ] up
yeah the baby owns you for a couple of
years what are you thinking of producing
milk just just eating because like in
the beginning like you're you've never
done it before so you have to like make
sure that you're eating enough so that
you're producing more yeah
we had a good party mom I was gonna say
one good thing about breastfeeding
though is that it actually helps you to
lose weight oh oh this [ __ ] better
Ethan and it also helps with your
vaginal muscles too because you burned
it's always calories yeah wait
breastfeeding makes your vagina contract
it makes your uterus get smaller faster
yeah yeah man I better have a that is
because your uterus is like oh they're
already on that step I better shrink
back okay I don't know any more tricks
tried your own breast milk no I tried my
friends a cantaloupe it's good really
like soy milk or like coconut milk or
something it's actually pretty good it's
like sweet cuz like cuz you know how I
had like feeding issues with Leia's she
was like fighting the bottle and
everything sauce like you know what I'm
gonna try formula versus breast milk and
like formula it tastes like they can
like it's just not good it smells like
it tastes it's rose I drank the breast
milk cause like oh no wonder she liked
it so much and I like got a little eater
yeah yeah very picky but but sometimes
your body just stops producing breast
milk and so you have to switch to
formula right and I hear women freaked
out about that too like I'm not a good
mother
I can't feed me oh yeah yeah there's a
lot of I think from this old mindset of
like that your purpose is to create
children and to provide sustenance for
children and if you fail at any of the
steps along the way then you're a
failure and you're broken
well right now the big thing was like
you have to breastfeed you have to you
have that you have to write you don't do
it you're not doing the you're not doing
the child any favors or there's a lot
more breastfeeding pressures there's a
lot and I [ __ ] hated it and then
there's like no like people will always
be like well this is better than formula
but there's literally like I've looked
into this there's no research right now
today that says that one is better than
the other yes in the beginning they do
when right as you give birth they do the
latching like they want to make sure
that the kid latches onto your boob and
they do want them to suck on it because
there's like that first I've heard what
it is but like that first oh yeah like
the golden milk
yeah and that's because it they keep
passing on like the antibodies to the
kid or whatever but after a certain
point there's no difference
so formula versus breastfeeding there's
no difference so couple things one I
read somewhere that when your body when
you're pregnant and there's something
around your body your baby actually
sends a little helper cells to fix your
body up for you that's really what team
are you want you to switch but also
cried in a switch T so that's super cute
like that's adorable his little baby's
like yellow I'm gonna fix my house up
real quick however students of
maintenance however let's talk about
post pregnancy before we run out of time
okay what I want to know is one how was
your first time having sex after vaginal
birth and today how are you like I would
be terrified of killing this child like
something's gonna happen oh dude I used
to have random ass thought yeah I
remember when Isaac was a newborn and we
were at home and I would have this weird
crazy idea that a plane was gonna crash
and kill him in bed yeah like what the
[ __ ] but it wasn't me cuz like that I
postpartum depression some women end up
having thoughts of like hurting their
penis and I didn't have that but I just
I was scared of the outside world so
much to the point where I had him in a
little bassinet thing in the in the
bathroom with me as I showered and every
two seconds I was wiping the fog away
making sure he was still breathing he
was still alive I was so obsessed see so
you're like that with your baby imagine
imagine how bad I'm gonna be what I've
got my first pet my snake I would check
every like 30 minutes hey are you
breathing buddy
cuz she would just leave yeah lay still
she would just lay still so now with the
baby I'm like terrified of just like
what if I do something wrong or like
SIDS
dude the first time I took Isaac to the
doctor because he he was born with
really long like his pinky nails were
really really long like certain male
like fingernails were really long so
then I trimmed it but then one pinky I
went a little too far in oh and I cut
him a little bit and he was bleeding and
I could not stop oh yeah I've done that
too so it was just that like it was the
guilt of that moment but then when I
took him in to the doctor the doctor was
like oh my God why would you do that
what a horrible I was like oh my god so
much so much hate because I was an 18
year old
the baby like I had so it for that there
have been better teen moms and there are
fully grown like adult mothers dude
[ __ ] yes so shitty yeah so then I
dude I [ __ ] broke down yeah when like
heyou me he's shamed me for that on top
of me already feeling shitty for hurting
my kid oh good so you end up going
through those experiences but honestly I
feel like at the end it just makes you
stronger cuz then I still raise my son
really well he's such a great [ __ ]
kid and alive yeah he's alive that's my
main concern like are you gonna be alive
to my kid just like everyday babies are
pretty resilient dude I heard yeah
you're fine and then the sex thing the
sex thing I know how was the first time
having sex after vaginal like oh you
didn't tear right I didn't tear to yours
I don't remember like how it was I was
all sorry yes I was scared I was scared
like I didn't want him to get near me
cuz like I was just like oh my god you
guys wait I I would say like at least a
month maybe like just bleeding stopped
yeah well I think people can still get
horny because after that I was like
don't touch me I think it's like I just
wanted to focus on the baby like I
didn't really care about anything else
but even then I was just like Oh like I
just I just had a baby come out of there
like yeah right well but yeah I don't
even remember how I was I just
remembered being like scared to even do
it yeah yeah since I did have the
stitches for me I was sore like it was
sore like like I would one I was
picturing the [ __ ] like it opening
again yeah that's what I would be scared
yeah but it was just tender even till
this day it's a little bit tender so
like because it already feels like he's
tearing me like for you because he's how
tall is he 6-4 6-4 and you're all talk
all of him him in my four siblings I
came out 10 pounds or more you are a
poor woman a poor woman like what was in
bone structure like all the mommies
equally as Geo sighs yeah with the moms
yeah cos I like them all cuz you're
saying all his siblings right yeah but
just one mom you're right I know you
said siblings with my brain
but you still said mom's did listen his
mom Breen okay 11 years ago have it be
pregnancy see and she's got birthing
hips okay I'm saying like that's why
they came out so big oh I'm just
terrified because I'm like genetically
yeah if I have a boy it you take the
average of the male and female height
and then you add two inches so you be
like six foot at least but not one is
born I want to find me the only way for
it I don't know it grows into that
height I'm not to find me a short small
big man so I just never heard ever damn
I want it I want to give birth though if
you're used to a baby sighs dick I mean
like a book you know you mean this the
big guy's eyes are baby buying a size up
like AG like you're waiting two years
before we [ __ ] get to kooky man I
just want to say thank you so much
Christina for being here for being so
brave and being so open and so positive
with just everything that's happened in
your pregnancy like you you really are
empowering a lot of people so thank you
for being here
ah you love you yeah yeah thank you guys
so much and we'll see you next week I
love you babies but not having babies